une porte s'ouvre sur plus de quinze
siècles d'histoire les cryptes nous
dévoilent leurs secrets sur les murs et
sur les voûtes un patrimoine
exceptionnel
ses peintures datent du 9ème siècle
elles sont parmi les plus anciennes de
france
alors on s'intéresse ici à l'expression
de son visage on parle de l'extase
détiennent son regard est fixe c'est le
moment précis où il a une vision où il
dit qu'il voit dieu et son fils à sa
droite sous leurs pieds
les visiteurs découvrent les tombeaux
d'une vingtaine d'évêques dont le
premier d'entre eux saint germain celui
qui donnera son nom à l'abbaye
ce sont des épitaphes ici on lit le mot
épiscopat d'autres ont été enterrés ici
et d'autres ici sur cette grille ronde
je suis vraiment surpris de la grandeur
de de cet espace soit en général les
cryptes c'est tout tout tout réduit avec
mon voir ce tombeau et c est là c'est
vraiment très impressionnant redécouvrir
cette abbaye c'est redécouvrir une
partie de l'histoire de la ville
d'auxerre ici l'architecturé
carolingienne pyromane free gothique
autant de traces d'un passé mouvementé
il y avait toute une succession de
comptes de construction de de
destruction de reconstruction
effectivement au fil des siècles
je vais te n'est que ça puisse exister
des choses pareilles à auxerre auxerre
est une ville industrielle et une ville
mais j'aurais jamais cru que ce soit une
ville religieuse comme ça
l'abbaye saint-germain est loin d'avoir
dévoilé tous ses secrets pour ceux qui
souhaiteraient les percées les cryptes
seront ouvertes tous les jours de l'été